for the rangers lead off hitter tonight
at least
he usually will bat lower in the order
when there's a right-handed starter
and he drills this one to center field
in the gap lewis comes over though and
he makes a nice play and isaiah connor
palefa
is retired here to start the game they
really strike out a lot that can really
be helpful for him tonight
oh this might be a no man's land who's
going to take it it's like killing it
all right good play
good communication out there angie
exactly kellnick is not shy
i don't know if we'll see it that much
today but there's a slider and he did go
so really nice first inning for
sheffield
just a couple of years ago in 2018 out
of high school
and he's a little bit late on that
fastball he hits it down the left field
line willie calhoun close to the wall
reaches up and makes a great catch
and willie calhoun continues to get it
done
with the glove very nice job there by
willie great job by willy
nine home runs 31 rbis for the long time
seattle mariners
third baseman and there is a breaking
ball he hits it the other way willie
calhoun though
future gold glover maybe makes a really
nice play oh how could he not give it to
the kid who got trampled by his rob
perfect moment either way nice job by
jordan lyles a quick one two three
and we're through one here in seattle i
just forgot to write it down
on sliders either way it was the best in
major league baseball whatever that 875
is but
this is a fastball that is drilled to
right center field but mitch haniger is
there not enough to get it out of here
garcia gives it a ride but it's good for
a first out here in the top of the
second
chatting about this before the game just
one thing that the justice sheffield
has been very good at historically is
when he does get runners on when he does
get a little bit
of trouble he finds a way to get himself
out of it see if he can here
that'll work
[Applause]
that's played by donovan walton to end
the inning so he's able to get out of
the inning
he's a couple runners stranded
there you go
kyle lewis starting to heat up again
good to have ty france
back in the lineup too there you go i
love it
i love it
i i call ty france a professional hitter
and that is just a professional
at-bat right there i mean it just
completely jammed
takes the ball the opposite way
grandma on the right side sliding play
by nick solac could throw over to nate
lowe
and nick solak saves the rangers
and saves me from having to answer that
question
two innings in the books the mariners
lead at one nothing
he wanted to see that pitch be effective
the one-two
swung on line to right field back as
haniger in front of the track
backpedaling makes the catch
one away here comes the one one
swung at hit hard right to kyle seeger
scoops it up throws the second for one
the relay by one the first
in time double play and that's the
inning
nicely turned the mariners have turned
more than anybody we go to the bottom of
the third
hems on top one nothing
kellock goes this time the pitch is low
throw through to second base the slide
he is safe
jerry kellnick swipes second base got a
great jump
[Applause]
comes the 2-2 and there's a change up
right on the corner 87 miles an hour how
about it
from jordan lyles for a called strike
three mitch haniger down
counting out three and two after that
swing in this and here comes the 3-2 and
it is another breaking ball
and another swing and a miss and you can
see the frustration
on kyle seeger's face as he continues to
struggle with breaking balls
well it's a promising start to the
inning a kellneck walk a stolen base
hanagar down on strikes seeger down on
strikes here comes kyle lewis
pitch from lyles swung on lifted to
right field this is hit well back as
gallow he's at the track he's at the
wall reaches up
there it goes gone
kyle lewis an opposite field blast
over the glove of gallo into the seats
the mariners extend the lead a two run
home run by lewis
it is three nothing m's
this pitch is chopped slowly toward
third seeger letting it roll it hits the
bag
adolesce magic man because there's so
much pressure right as a young player
and you feel like you're the only one
who has failed as joey gallo hits this
one to deep center field
over the head of kyle lewis garcia is
thinking about scoring he's going to
stay at third
and it is a one-out double for joey
gallo and the rangers in business here
in the top of the fourth inning
this is chris davis steps in now and the
2-1 from
sheffield and this one is lace to left
field and but caught by jared kelney
garcia will tag easily and score and so
it is
a sac fly but off the bat look like
there might have been a chance for a
little bit more but the rangers will
take it they are on the board
here in seattle and they trail it now
three to one
the high school in tulsa as he lines one
to right field but joey gallo is there
and the inning is over good job by
jordan
a couple of strikeouts as he pitches
around a double
we are through four in seattle and here
comes the first pitch to kind of for
left and he hits the ball to the right
side
with nobody home culverson around third
here's the throw it's not gonna be in
time but now jose trevigno
is stuck in a rundown between second and
third the tag
from kyle seeger and trevino is going to
be out
and no doubt a base running mistake is
tony beasley has a word with
jose trevino really really good swing
from isaiah connor felefa pinwheels the
bat around
gripping it with those red batting
gloves masevich set
his 3-2 pitch swinging a mess he got him
the cutter that he whiffs through and
masevich
strikes out the side one two three down
go the rangers
that should be it
nice turn strong arm from crawford well
done
there you go yeah
well done all right so we're headed to
the bottom of the egg
the mariners escape and the tradition
continues
unlike any other which is kyle seger
getting breaking balls and
kyle seeger not hitting breaking balls
three pitches and it's a strikeout for
john king we're going to the ninth
inning
rangers with their final opportunity to
try to tie this ball game
3-2 on the way to martin swing and it's
popped up foul first base side
near the dugout ty francis there has
some room at the track he
makes the catch and the ball game is
over